This episode of DNews is presented by Kay
Jewelers.
Every kiss begins with Kay.
Attraction feels kind of crazy when it happens,
like, there are times when I have to physically
stop myself and say, "Trace.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?!"
What's going on
in here?!
Humans are big animals, big dumb animals.
You, me, them, everybody; we're all slaves
to our brain chemicals and biology -- and
when we fall in love, that's a big one.
Obviously, we can make our own choices, but
attraction, lust and love are driven by animal
nature.
We want to find a good genetic match, mate,
reproduce, raise young -- it's part of our
ancient programming!
In the modern day, we have more social restrictions,
but essentially the brain is handling stuff
backstage and it's doing a poor job of it.
According to biological anthropologist Helen
Fisher, "Romantic love is akin to an addiction."
Yeah, you might as well face it.
We're addicted to love.
But in a very specific way; scientists believe
when we're attracted to someone we're subconsciously
weighing their genes, looks, and cultural,
religious and socioeconomic backgrounds.
As we grow to know someone, the brain releases
hormones which cause us to bond with someone,
and different levels of different hormones
will affect different people differently.
Which is why love stinks.
Hormones like dopamine which is for rewards
like cocaine or chocolate, norepinephrine
which causes excitement like adrenaline, or
serotonin which is the chemical that makes
you feel like you're going temporarily insane
are all squeezed out of the brain and into
the bloodstream…
In fact, studies from Rutgers University found
four chemicals affect the attraction cycle
-- dopamine, serotonin, testosterone and estrogen/oxytocin
-- and they were each tied to a personality
type!
According to the studies, the more active
a person's dopamine centers the more reward-driven
and impulsive they are in love.
Serotonin-heavy people were less anxious,
but more risk averse.
These two groups tend to be attracted to others
like them; but sometimes as Paula told us,
Opposites attract.
Testosterone-heavy people are analytical and
competitive; while estrogen/oxytocin-heavy
people were more empathetic, trusting and
social; each of these groups were more likely
to be attracted to the OTHER.
It's important to note, that none of these
hormone types determined along sex lines...
In the brain, males can be estrogen/oxytocin
heavy, testosterone heavy or serotonin heavy…
and females can be any of those things too
… It can go any way.
With all these chemicals squirting every which
way, messes can happen, but if the pairing
makes it through the crazy serotonin stage,
OTHER chemicals come into maintain a coupling.
Vasopressin and oxytocin are released after
the initial love addiction to form longer
term bonds.
A study in Social Cognitive and Affective
Neuroscience found that during the initial
love period, the Ventral Tegmental Area was
very active, as was the areas controlling
addiction, but as love wore on, the brain
changed.
When in new love, people report pining and
anxiety, and a heated NEEDINESS but after
20 years -- married couples had more activity
in the posterior globus pallidus, which is
associated with pleasure and pain relief.
This part of the brain usually activates when
you eat to the best food or take morphine!
Other parts of the brain showed pair-bonding
for long-term couples is similar to maternal
love, and even stronger than love for friends!
In the end, the initial spark of attraction
might be based on pheromones, genes, hormones
and looks, but a strong bond can be created
too.
What do you think?
Are you a slave to your brain?
Which of these hormone personality types are
you?